vou contar pra vocês hoje um pouco sobre
uma jornada de cura
no final não sei se vocês vão entender
como cura mas enfim vamos lá vou tentar
ver o que você entende se então outro
slide neste site a kyoto dizendo que ele
parecia não tem cura
não tem padrão quer dizer é porque
porque quis e não tem padrão é uma
doença com diferentes origens
ela causa diferentes tipos de crise nas
pessoas e eu fui um epiléptico a desde a
primeira infância até os 20 anos
com 20 anos e me curei com através de
uma cirurgia mas a por ela ser uma
doença dinâmica é muito difícil
privilégio lidar com essa doença
justamente por isso até o trouxe aqui se
vocês tiverem interesse de aprofundar um
pouco mais no assunto o grande projecto
recente
dentro dessa área de interesse dentro da
pesquisa sobre epilepsia é um projeto
tocado por uma uma fundação chamada aqui
o que é o vídeo em que ela é apenas a
ele genetics agente ativo em que eles
estão tentando fazer um mapeamento
genético de todos os dos epiléticos dos
estados unidos para tentar entender as
origens e saber como é o comportamento
só a causa da doença a origem e como ela
se e se manifesta nas pessoas mas também
com qual existe um padrão de
comportamento entre as peças exemplo
elétricos
então assim quando eu me curei eu tive
uma cura clínica mas uma não uma coisa
psicológica porque isso aconteceu como
eu nasci com a doença
eu nasci epilético e eu sempre fui
político
eu nunca deixei de ser epilético porque
eu não sabia o que era uma vida sem
epilepsia
então depois de um depois de um tempo da
minha cura eu enfrentei uma situação de
depressão proposta temática que
aconteceu eu não conseguir viver sem
eletricidade
eu era dependente das crises epilépticas
é meio curioso dizer isso né mas é era
emocionante reflexiva
eu não sabia quando que isso acontecer
então estava sempre com aquele medo
assim quando isso vai acontecer de novo
eu tinha idéia dos dias que não
acontecia porque pra vocês que talvez
não conheçam
beneficia uma um dos um dos motivos
pelos quais ela se manifesta é através
do cansaço físico e eu sempre gostei de
praticar esporte
eu sempre fui uma criança muito agitada
eu era imperativo quando era criança em
fazer de tudo corria fazer atletismo na
escola jogava ou jogavam futebol na rua
skate e bicicleta sempre tava quebrando
fazendo alguma coisa como os meus pais
diziam ele sempre tentar fazer alguma
coisa que era diferente todo mundo eu
sempre escolho um esporte que não era
muito normal para praticar as áreas
todas que eu falei pra vocês eram mas
por exemplo surfava não podia surfar mas
enfim me tirava no mar e ver o que
acontecia
depois quando quando eu quando eu me
curei eu comecei a assimilar todas essas
coisas que eu falei pra vocês
só que de uma forma diferente por conta
dessa depressão pós traumática
eu fui um dia estava conversando com os
pais no almoço ea ea e eu contei para a
fim de fazer nada minha mãe não está com
depressão vai num teatro em conversa com
ela a edição está com uma depressão pós
traumática de beleza voltei pra casa
precisa encarar a depressão pós
traumática conviver com epilepsia muito
pior mesmo tempo pau da barraca e e fui
ver a vida peguei os remédios que ele
tinha me dado também 23 jogar tudo no
lixo e comecei a assimilar um pouco
melhor
tudo que tinha acontecido então assim
certa forma foi mais uma vez que assume
um risco de enfrentar alguma coisa
porque eu peguei a depressão e fui lá no
fundo do poço com ela e eu comecei a
descobrir várias coisas que me ajudaram
a ser quem eu sou
a primeira delas foi vulnerabilidade o
que eu aprendi sobre vulnerabilidade que
beneficia como eu podia estar falando
com vocês aqui hoje e de repente eu caí
no chão que começar a me bater e tem uma
crise epiléptica primeira coisa que
aprendi então há sim risco
a apresentação contou fazendo pra vocês
aqui eu não li ela nenhuma vez
eu peguei escrevi sobre se tinha algo
útil portugueses
vamos ver o que acontece eu estou sempre
buscando formas de eu me sentir
vulnerável
eu acabei construindo isso naturalmente
a segunda coisa foi sobre o convívio mas
nem assim quem tem epilepsia não também
não passa assim mas eu nunca estava
sozinho
estava eu me a consciência que me
ajudava a brigar com epilepsia e
se é sempre do meu lado e então assim e
isso me ajudou assimilar que tipo sempre
nunca está sozinho e está sempre
convivendo com alguém né e o convívio o
que eu mais aprendi sobre o convívio
nesse tempo foi que eu sem querer eu
comecei a me relacionar com muita gente
e gente diferente porque poucas pessoas
entendiam da minha doença então eu
precisava entender a minha doença e
dividir com as pessoas as experiências
que eu tinha toda vez que eu encontrava
uma pessoa era uma situação de
aprendizado diferente porque eu tinha
que explicar aquela pessoa o que eu
tinha
da forma que ela pudesse entender de
certa forma esse convívio também me
ajudou a desenvolver o um pouco empatia
quando fiquei internado no no hospital
fiquei quase um mês internado por
cirurgia e enfim tudo cheguei lá tinham
dez pessoas eram cinco leitos para
homens e 5 anos para mulheres
o conversível conversavam no dia a dia
com as pessoas e tal antes da cirurgia
de uma semana até ontem fizeram 14 anos
foram completados 14 anos e que eu dei
entrada no hospital no próximo dia 22 de
julho fazem 14 anos que eu fiz a
cirurgia a cirurgia enfim e depois da
cirurgia que eu fiquei do tempo de
recuperação eu comecei a conversar com
as pessoas que estavam se preparando
para fazer a cirurgia o que conversei
com elas e talvez pintar vai ficar tudo
bem como foi praticado ou não tudo
tranquilo
daí tem baixo do hospital etapas ou
mesmo má voltar lá pra visitar essas
pessoas
as enfermeiras chegaram pra mim o
marcelo não quer vir aqui mais vezes
conversar com as pessoas
posso vir mas porque isso não é que
todas as pessoas que têm o conversor que
se acalmaram foram mais tranqüilo pela
cirurgia o que falei pra elas foi
basicamente sobre isso sobre
vulnerabilidade sobre convívio e também
sobre curiosidade a enfrentarem a
experiência da cirurgia como algo novo é
tentar descobrir mais sobre ele o que o
que te trouxe até aqui qual é a tua
história enfim tudo isso estava com
depressão a gente com depressão e
tentando assimilar todas essas coisas ea
curiosidade ela ela me ajudava muito
nessa relação de convívio também
a habilidade que eu comecei a pesquisar
sobre coisas que realmente me colocassem
à margem ou que qualquer situação do
mundo fosse colocasse o mundo do jeito
que é
a margem por exemplo um dia sem que eu
comecei a ler sobre anarquismo
outro dia eu comecei a ler sobre sobre o
animismo enfim cada dia eu ia descendo
no universo diferente pra entendam
entender um pouco as coisas e como se
construiu as relações humanas
tudo isso me levou a entender que eu
tinha que tentar voltar a ser quem eu
era antes e quando em 2008 fumar em são
paulo e sem querer o cair do lado do do
parque do ibirapuera eu comecei a correr
aqui é uma coisa boa
vou correr correr então e daí quando
estava ocorrendo um dia o piscinão mas
eu tenho que fazer mais alguma coisa eu
lembrei de um desejo de infância quando
tinha 12 anos
eu assisti uma uma reportagem sobre um
cara que corria 100 quilômetros
lembrei dele tal foi lá no youtube e
procure dutta o cara tava reportagem a
que assisti em 1992 sobre valmir nunes
que o cara era tricampeão mundial de
ultramaratona ele corria 100 quilômetros
em seis horas eu eu quero significar
isso era março de 2010
fui lá no google procurei outra maratona
encontrei uma com inscrições abertas uma
outra maratona de 24 horas no rio de
janeiro
peguei me atirei em quatro meses eu me
preparei
antes desta corrida participei de duas
depois prima de 10 quilômetros uma de 30
quilômetros de ocorrência de 24 horas
ocorre cem quilômetros nessa de 24 horas
nunca tinha medido distância que eu
fazia
só que ele convivendo com essas pessoas
e tal ultramaratonistas néon da parte um
mundo diferente pessoas que correm muito
e coisa e tal
eu comecei a ver que esses caras eles
ele se mobilizavam muito assim tipo para
se motivar os habitantes pois teme que o
lema sim há sempre sorrindo sempre
conseguiu num luxo pra mim não tinha
gosto eu não entendia por que tanta
motivação sendo a gente sempre sorrindo
feliz e que corremos
tino não não tenho não vamos lá campeão
vamos lá guerreiro para fu e idéia eu
comecei assim mas porque eu não sinto
nada com isso né
comecei a e de repente comecei a
entender o que estava acontecendo
esses caras que buscam motivação livros
de autoajuda esgotavam música tipo tem
um cara que eu conheço que ele sempre
assistir assisti escuta raúl quando ele
está lá em baixo assim ela tente outra
vez de raul ele vai lá e não escuto
tente outra vez eu consegui ir adiante
eu pensava não fazer o penso não foi
adiante horror diante bem racional assim
eu comecei a entender que na realidade
eu já tinha uma cabeça de outro
maratonista como epilético a resistência
psicológica para conseguir superar o
estresse físico
eu já tinha até porque não sei se vocês
sabem a crise epiléptica dependendo de
como ela ela acontece
ela te derruba fica com musculatura tão
tensa e depois que a corda é como se
tivesse jogado uma partida de futebol
tanto que muitas vezes eu ficava deitada
na cama total com o corpo todo dolorido
para fazer parte da minha natureza eu
cresci assim eu me desenvolvi dessa
forma a beleza recorrendo que se puxa
que legal já só que nesses caras eu
estou recém começando né
só que com o tempo essa essa frieza com
que eu vi um negócio começou a fazer
buscar outras coisas eu comecei a ver
limitações dentro desse universo de
outra maratona e não só de outra
maratona de corridas qual é que que foi
começou a ser o meu principal
questionamento essa busca por
performance
essa busca por que esse é o melhor por
encontrar sempre o melhor suplemento por
encontrar enfim a corrida perfeita para
participar
não sei o que é para si um lugar
perfeito para correr se inscrever e
participar de uma competição enfim eu
não consegui sentir muito muito bem com
essa coisa assim de querer ser melhor a
gente não correr na minha cabeça
funcionava assim vamos lá vão se
divertir com as coisas e nesse dia que
essa foto foi em 2011 quando o
completei dez anos da minha cirurgia eu
decidi que eu ia comemorar correndo a
150 quilômetros
isso aqui foi na serra do faxinal se
vocês já foram para cambará do sul e nos
aparados da serra eu saí de são joão do
sul subir a serra do faxinal correndo e
fui quase até são josé dos ausentes e
nesse e nesse processo decorrer
teve um momento assim que que baixou o
espírito desse cara é isso aqui que eu
quero fazer
eu não quero competição eu quero me
perder eu quero em jogar num no mato e
ver o que acontece eu que queria que o
encontro e tal
no ano passado eu conheci um cara
chamado william galston ele criou um
método chamado transcendência para
desenvolver a paz
basicamente é isso em um tweet e se o
cara faz mas é muito mais complexo
se vocês tiverem interesse transcendendo
ponto org é a organização dele e eu
comecei a lembrar do que tinha feito os
esportes que tinha praticado e tal eu
desse cara performance pacífica que que
isso performance pacífica skatistas
entende surfista entende disso nada mais
é do que uma visão de integralidade com
um lugar onde se pratica o esporte não é
por exemplo praticar uma corrida e ficar
trancado dentro de um curral de largada
e correção dos caras estão dizendo é
correr por onde tu quiser se integrando
com o ambiente consegue assimilar muito
melhor todos os problemas que implicam
aquele lugar onde está praticando o
esporte se integrar com as pessoas é o
que os surfistas fazem protegendo as
praias conseguindo trazer pessoas para
próximo do esporte desenvolver pessoas
através do esporte é o que o skate faz
com a arquitetura da cidade é o que
muitos pop o brasileiro faz o futebol
por exemplo jogar na rua sabe mas o
corredor não se envolve tanto assim ele
acaba correndo dentro de parques ele
acaba correndo só nas nos lugares onde
os organizadores de provas coloca as
pessoas para participar e deu esse cara
tá aí performance pacífica mas porque o
pacífico porque quando a gente se
distancia da performance a gente
aproveita muito mas não fico mais refém
de um relógio
eu estou em paz comigo mesmo e eu
descobri isso que quando morava em são
paulo corria porque não aguentava viver
naquela cidade
e quando eu voltei pra cá eu comecei a
me relacionar uma forma muito melhor
a corrida justamente por isso porque não
precisava correr para lutar contra a
cidade porque eu corria 20 quilômetros
por dia em são paulo para o trabalho no
final do dia voltava de trem era a forma
que encontrei de enfrentar o trânsito da
cidade da então nesse ano eu decidi
começar a botar em prática algumas
idéias desse cara e disse que estava
tudo na minha cabeça também
eu creio travessia dos vários que a
travessia dos vales
eu defini um traje um eu fiz um define
um raio em torno de novo hamburgo que a
cidade onde eu vivo e decidi que vou
começar a correr pelos lugares onde
muita gente não corre entre dentro desse
raio aqui então eu comecei a definir
alguns caminhos o primeiro caminho que
eu fiz foi agora em abril fez 87
quilômetros entre novo hamburgo e santo
antônio da patrulha por uma rota
completamente alternativa
isso aqui foi um dos registros que eu
fiz
talvez muitos de vocês não conheçam se
passaram por esses lugares que no
interior de taquara
isso aqui é um núcleo de construções
antigas de 1920 em 1910 e tal de quando
começou a ser colonizada região
e é justamente isso que estou buscando
com esse projeto eu defino ele como um
curioso o como turismo autoguiado a pé
eu crio caminhos jogo eles dentro do
google maps lá com o ponto a minha casa
e ponto b qualquer lugar
o jogo lá e vejo que a minha intimidade
normalmente manda pela br 116 com a rs
239 digo nós vamos procurar onde é verde
uma no meio do mato e eu pego ele tá
beleza tem 80 km de 61 anos um pra mim
então jogo dentro do telefone celular
dentro do google trilhas para isso e me
joga não sei se lá tem estrada - o
google está dizendo vou lá
esse aqui foi o último que eu fiz foi no
dia 1º de junho em que eu saí de três
coroas e fiz um caminho por trás do
morro ferrabraz talvez alguns de vocês
aqui conhecia mas ele é bem famoso por
ser uma por ter uma plataforma de de vôo
livre eu conseguir fazer um caminho ele
que ocorrido mais ou menos na borda da
serra lhe desse por sapiranga tal
cheguei em novo hamburgo
isso aqui foi eu fiz no meu primeiro dia
de férias
para aguentar o que ela achava de
verdade eu fui lá e essa aqui foi uma
das listas que eu encontrei no caminho
estava em dia bem frio e estava as
nuvens estavam cobrindo todas as cidades
lá embaixo e eu estava em cima do do
caminho então assim ultra maratonista
ele precisa ser um epiléptico para fazer
a vontade da consciência prevalecer
sobre o corpo
nessa só que ele consegue fazer muito
mais e é o que estou tentando buscar
provar que o atlético consegue também o
epilético ele tem muito essa essa
necessidade do ultra maratonista de
tentar ser um cara mas há como é que é
introspectivo mas sem se deprime e assim
o que o que eu quero mostrar para vocês
aqui hoje nada mais é do que assim é
às vezes a cura ela não vai chegar
porque não estou curado não deixa de ser
um epiléptico eu continuo sendo o
atlético só que eu decidir com essa essa
dificuldade que eu tive de enfrentar a
epilepsia construir seus próprios
caminhos e não sei se isso aqui um dia
vai me dar dinheiro se isso aqui um dia
vai me levar pra algum lugar está me
levando mas é da forma que eu tô vendo
se não se por exemplo qualquer coisa que
aconteça para encontrar a cura o
importante é que encontra o próprio
caminho eu descobri isso quando eu eu
estava no hospital que houve várias
pessoas com epilepsia que não sabiam que
iam fazer e eu já tinha feito muita
coisa ali porque eu consegui encontrar
os meus próprios caminhos então convívio
vulnerabilidade conhecimento são
basicamente as grandes cultivos como
flexível e que eu quero deixar para
vocês e isso se vocês vão encontrar em a
cura seja lá o que for eu acho que não a
gente não segura só de doença encontra
os seus caminhos e sejam felizes
muito obrigado